The trickiest part of this
problem is setting it up.
We need to figure out the correct
placement of the values
on the left-hand side on
the butterfly network.
Even though as we go forward here,
omega is going to be negative
i instead of i because we're
doing the inverse transform.
We need to order the values according
to the omega that was used
in the forward transform.
So thus, omega to the 1 is i, and omega
to the third power is negative i here.
Carrying the calculation forward
a level we obtain these results here.
Then for this last level we have
4 plus 8 which is 12, good.
Then for this next one we want
omega to the first power times
this and because we're doing the inverse
transform that omega is negative i.
And that gives us this result here of 4.
For the next one,
we multiply the odd term by negative 1.
So that gives us negative 4 here.
And for the last one we multiply
by our omega cubed which is i.
We multiply that by the odd term, and
combining that with this
gives us a total of 8.
To get the original polynomial,
we divide by n, 4 in this case.
Thus we have that the original
polynomial was 3 plus x
minus x squared plus two X cubed.
And you can check that
that all works out.
Note that there is a sense in which
the ordering over here was arbitrary.
We could have done the forward
transform with omega equal to -i,
in which case I would've
flipped these and
then the inverse transform
would've used i here and -i here.
And that would have given
us the same result.